all right late the great Mather great
where'd you grow up where you from I
grew up in Los Angeles south-central
know various parts the west lake
district a little bit of downtown during
my childhood on the east side of south
central just a little bit you know I
bounced around a lot okay how was your
childhood you had both parents have both
my parents until my father went to
prison when I was age ten years old so
how was your childhood after that me and
my mother ended up on Skid Row in Los
Angeles and um I started going in and
out of juvenile hall and eventually the
California Youth Authority for robbery
you get five years and got out when I
was just about 20 years old
where'd you go from there
got out winning as a boy came out as a
man and the world was new to me I grew
up you know irregularly because the ye
stretch and uh I ended up going to New
York to see a different world try
something different so what'd you see in
New York he was really fast it was
foreign to me it was downtown Los
Angeles times five I didn't handle
sourcing income
I wasn't technically runaway because I
was ready to dealt but I was equivalent
to a runaway because I had adolescent
frame of mind and I were trying to find
my way and I ended up familiarizing
myself with the pimping culture so you
had to baby
took her under their wing and showed you
the way well not really um I was in a
Hunts Point area of South Bronx and um I
started hanging out with pimps and stuff
and it was encouraging me to bring a
girl out there they liked my swag they
liked my West Coast leg and uh I had a
girl choose me out of nowhere as far as
she wanted a boyfriend figure she's at
pence before Bishnoi was vulnerable and
green to the game so she want a
boyfriend figure and uh tell me if she
if I allow you to be with me under the
circumstances of her being a prostitute
that the money will be for the both of
us then I took her up on offer because I
need
the money without intending on pursuing
her career as a pimp and uh it kind of
started from there so you start out with
tell me about your first the first girl
you had that was the one like is she um
she was a black girl she was tad bit
younger than me and um it didn't last
too long because when she was really
wanting was trying to see the the the
factors that she wished she had seen in
season pimps and kind of manipulated me
into giving her the boyfriend attention
that she would have got from them guys
but you know she wasn't being spoiled
with that from seasoned pimp so she
called somebody green vulnerable and uh
you know got what she wanted out of me
you know and uh that was about it but I
stepped my foot in the water I got a
taste of it I like I like that fast easy
money don't you go from there uh I went
on ahead and try to keep going with
getting as many girls as I could under
the circumstances of working under my
employ and uh but my career didn't go
full-fledged and this was 1999 my career
didn't go full-fledged in it uh I came
back to Los Angeles and was selling
drugs and stuff like that but I wasn't
acceptance of having a prostitute
working for me when the opportunity
presented itself but it wasn't a
priority to get one I mean you got more
into the game that at one point I would
say 2002 and Hollywood on Sunset you
know what I saw guys my age and my age
bracket couple years younger even
driving nice cars having things having
three or four girls at the least and I'm
like wow you know I you know it made me
it motivated me it's saying wow these
guys can do it you know I want in I was
playing with the game I want it in have
you done prison time for this yes I have
on two different occasions the penalties
are much harsher now than they used to
be the penalties if the human human
trafficking enhancement is involved here
in California's more hearts but you know
that's if the girl says she worked for a
pimp on your fear forest threat the rest
threat intimidation courtesan
you know
it's that aggravates all the charges if
it happens to be a minor under the human
trafficking statute with the factors I
just mentioned the aggravating factors
to carry fifteen years of life but just
a regular pimping charge here in
California carries six years max that's
just for being convicted to learn living
off their earnings and proceeds of a
prostitute sixty no six years or six
years if three years is low term four
years mid term is six years as the high
time so how many girls do you have now
well based on this is a public interview
yes I would rather not I said that if
you had girls what sex is with it I mean
what races would they be
I prefer Hispanic and white women /
black women sometimes I accept a black
woman but her her mental capacity and
her beauty factors have to be equivalent
to that of a Latino or white woman what
kind of money do they bring in it
depends on where they're working what
method you're using to catch their dates
you know it depends on what kind of
woman it is what caliber of a woman it
is you know uh I can't take a woman that
doesn't do no drugs at all and work her
in the drug infested area because the
clients are gonna be offering less money
and it's gonna be insulting to her and I
both but uh and I can't tell your girl
that's strung out on drugs and try to
put her out there with the with the with
the girls that ain't on drugs that's
getting approximately 80 to 120 dollars
a day and expect her to keep up with
that because you know drugs is their
primary and a pimp and having a manager
while they're doing what they're doing
is a secondary so if a girl that's on
hardcore controlled substance goes out
there makes it $120 in one day she's
gonna get lazy you want to come home and
he lab right on how she made that much
and one whopper think it's really
something to her as a drug addict and I
want to get high and waste time to where
else to me it's nothing
so the amount they make as I said
depends on where they work at what their
personal factors are as far as drug
usage or not
and what method to be in youth for them
to get two days let me give you hundred
percent of their money if they live with
me they put a hundred percent of my hand
to manage but it's not giving it to me
as though it's a donation and they're
not living off it I'm more like an
accounting form and they get protection
from you or something they get
protection they get inspiration the
motivation they get a they get guidance
you know the security factors for the
most part come and play through the
instructions that I give them to not get
herself into certain situations you know
you know if a person has more than one
girl you know he can't be he can't split
itself in infractions and be there
physically to protect each one but if
she takes heed to what the pimp tells
her to do that she's not gonna find
herself oftentimes in situations where
she's going to be in the face of danger
so that's that's where the protection
comes in right there however you know
tricks and clients are still
unpredictable it could be the coolest
guy that she screens out and he'll still
out of nowhere uh unexpectedly do some
weirdo stuff once around traffic it
happens that's that's inevitable and in
your style
I mean I've learned that there are many
different types of pimps some are ladies
men and some are using intimidation or
force and there's so many different
styles what would you say your style is
I would say my style has a lot of
diversity to it and I say that because I
apply whichever variation of styles I
may have depending on what kind of woman
it is you know she's a knucklehead
who's not going to respect a pimp or
respect any man figure in any type of
partnership relationship she's in she's
a knucklehead then it's gonna be a lot
of hostility during our partnership and
you know it might lead to it might lead
to things that hostility inevitably
induces however if she's a small chick
then all the gentlemen will come out of
me so I applied two factors of my
characteristics toward the woman
according to her behavior and are some
of the girls taking advantage of their
of their John's there's like most
getting their wallets getting their
phones either jewelry whatever most
definitely because a lot of the women if
if you know they settle for that line of
business that trade but sometimes in the
back of a mind or on the forefront
they'll express that they don't enjoy
what they're doing so it's like a
compromise
it's an ambivalence they enjoy for the
fast proceeds you know then they hate it
based on the downside of things they got
to go through but as far as a
alternative sources of income an
alternative way of a getting the
proceeds from a trick other than flat
backing or giving [ __ ] of stuff if
they see an opportunity for they go for
it and they don't feel sorry for him
because he should have been out there
buying [ __ ] anyway because one classic
one classic Universal factor in that
matter is you know why should I feel
sorry for him when he's doing something
that he doesn't want his daughter out
here doing or he doesn't want his wife
out of doing but I'm out of doing it and
he's all for it so it's kind of hard to
be sympathetic for him he becomes a
victim to get his pocket clip do you
have sex with your girls uh it all
depends on the kind of girl pimps or
myself included has had sex with girls
under my employ
but there's girls that uh you know it's
kind of a business understanding from
the jump it's a strictly a business
relationship they don't want to have sex
with a pimp because they don't want
emotions get involved or misconstrue it
for a boyfriend/girlfriend relationship
where it'll interfere with the business
aspect of it because you know women by
nature when they have sex with a man
they're thinking he's already been paid
because you know they're aware that
every man does enjoy blessing and nut so
whereas a pimp has to make sure
strategically that there's no confusion
and no no misunderstanding that business
is one thing and pleasure is another and
the girl has to understand the
difference between a slick and a trick
and if a pimp has too much sex with his
girls and won't save some footage tricks
that's gonna run it off eventually so
you know the lady can't have no
impression that you know he's somewhat
equivalent to a trick because he wants
to get in my pants all day so I have to
go out and work for him quote-unquote I
have to go out and work for him and then
come back and have sex with him - that's
kind of a turn-off what personality
trait do you
that helps you do this makes you a good
thing well they're not to speak and
articulate valid points rational point
that's great good management skills you
know for girl makes enough money
whatever it is that's her main her
maintenance consist of that's uh I'm
gonna make sure she always has it what
qualities do you look for in a girl uh
number one competence more than anything
else even more than looks I look for
competence because communication means
everything and only a competent person
could communicate good but it was the
craziest thing you've seen in your years
of doing this um wow there's so many of
them trying to think which one uh I
could share you mean craziest thing as
far as that line of business right yeah
exactly
craziest thing I've seen that light at
Venice one time in Hollywood a girl had
got almost kidnapped by John it wasn't a
girl of mine she had almost got
kidnapped by John and so she was naked
in his car and she jumped out naked
while she could okay and she was running
down the street naked and then got hit
by a car on Sunset Boulevard back in the
early 2000 that's one of the craziest
things I've seen that's very bad what
are you proudest of in your life do you
have kids uh as a matter of fact I do
and do you raise them now I have a son
up and um and another state okay and uh
I just met him for the first time
recently
his mother was once upon a time under my
employ he's a real good kid you know uh
has good manners and stuff I think he he
inherited all of my good jeans
okay oh my good personality traits and
uh yeah I just met him for the first
time man and it was a good feeling and
what do you pursue well let's see I'm
proud of so many things hold on me
I believe I'm proud of my intelligence
yeah
what's more important to you love or
money
well I don't believe there's a such
thing as love
I believe you're disgusting is respect I
would rather somebody respect me to love
me because love is just a word that's
used in substitute of expressing some
kind of endearment feelings of
endearment or some rights whereas
respect is you often demonstrate it okay
and then money money money is a coupon
for survival without it you know you
ain't [ __ ] so uh I cherish respect and
money both the same excellent lately
great thank you so much for sharing your
story and good luck with wherever you go
from here
you're very welcome thank you man
you